on a suivi cette conférence de presse
ensemble on a senti Emmanuel Macron
finalement très attentif à la situation
en Moldavie est-ce que c'est nouveau ça
pour un chef d'État français je crois
que la dernière déplacement Moldavie
pour un président c'était Jacques Chirac
oui c'est-à-dire qu'après la
l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique on
a considéré que des pays comme la
Moldavie d'autres anciennes républiques
soviétiques restaient et c'était vrai de
fait dans le giron ou dans du moins dans
l'orbite de Moscou
dans la réalité c'est plus compliqué que
ça parce que on a effectivement un peu
mis sous le tapis sous-évalué la volonté
d'émancipation de ces ex républiques
soviétiques parfois d'ailleurs tiraillé
par des intérêts divergents et
contradictoires la Moldavie c'est le cas
et sur le plan énergétique elle dépend
de Moscou et sur un plan on va dire
culturel les aspirations à un ordre
démocratique à une bonne gouvernance
toutes ces choses qui font quand en
Europe on considère qu'elles sont
superflues alors que on voit bien que
dans ces pays-là c'est capital pour les
citoyens pour tout le monde et bien ces
pays ont cette aspiration et on en a pas
tenu compte pourquoi parce que aussi il
y avait cette espèce de doxa qu'on a en
Occident en Europe occidentale vis-à-vis
de la Russie de Poutine qu'on avait
j'espère que c'est du passé qui
consistait à dire il faut absolument
soutenir Vladimir Poutine même s'il mène
son peuple à la Queen il faut le
soutenir il faut croire en la
rationalité du personnage et ce qui vont
venir en parlant d'aspiration
démocratique que ça soit les citoyens
russes dont je rappelle qu'ils sont
aussi les premières victimes de Vladimir
Poutine les citoyens russes ceux dans
ces pays anciennement républiques la
Moldavie la Géorgie l'Ukraine non tout
ça on la méprisé on a favorisé le
dialogue avec Vladimir Poutine lequel
dialogue en l'espace de trois mois à
valsé par-dessus les bords de de du
navire européen et tout cela au
détriment de tout le monde donc la
révision déchirante qu'il faut opérer et
manuel Macron et en quelque sorte de
cette révision parce que il est
président au moment où les choses se
passent cette révision consiste à dire
ayons l'écoute soyons attentif à ceux
qui justement ont des revendications sur
le plan de la démocratie la plus
élémentaire la plus stricte et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut tenir compte de la
Moldavie mais après on arrive forcément
aux limites du genre c'est à dire que ce
pays est James André l'a rappelé et
tiraillé et gangrené par un certain
nombre de de travers séparatistes que ça
soit la transmisserie ou la gagosie et
de ce fait là on est obligé de tenir
compte de cette fragilité de ces pays
qui sont devenus encore plus fragiles
parce qu'on n'a pas prêté attention à
eux et c'est cela qu'il faut corriger
alors évidemment ça ne se fait pas à
l'échelon ni même d'un mandat ni même
d'un second mandat d'un président de la
République française mais au moins on
peut espérer que les choses soient
disons initiés et qu'elle soit sur de
mon rail merci Gauthier pas